what's going on with this girl with the
teeth
chris christian rock is that her name oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel like um
you guys have had quite the um
online uh drama
she is she claiming that she's pregnant
by you right now
um
see she's like uh
very like an impulse type of person like
you know she's kind of guy i could tell
yeah she kind of got like real issues
mentally to where she she freaks out
that's what she calls it mm-hmm
so
she was on the first blue gc
okay but she hung around
um well her tooth fell out during the
show
so wow so yes i i kind of was like okay
well let me make a positive out of this
negative
uh her tooth fell out on the first
season in the first season yeah did she
get punched or something no um
well it goes down at the blue gc mansion
oh you never know we didn't have
helicopters pull up
sheesh but now basically what happened
is my bm was watching the show she got
mad she was feeling some type of way
about i guess my interaction with them
or their interaction with me
so one night her and her friends all got
drunk and decided to go over there and
confront people oh [ __ ] your baby mama
yes my baby mom
[ __ ] bro
i'm like what are you doing like you're
[ __ ] up the back here
man so it's kind of her fault in a way
that
me and kashan even
stood this long together right because
at the end of the day i felt like you
kind of felt bad yeah so i'm like yeah
let me make this negative positive
so boom
as they confronted her she runs
out
you know because it's too many of them
so she runs out of the door but on her
way out she hit her face
on this uh zebra i got in the living
room
so her tooth was like hanging
so then we took it to the dentist and
they had to pull it
so that's how that's how that happened
it's pretty epic right that just kind of
happens one random day at the bgc i'm
just sitting upstairs talking yeah yeah
so what we're going to do we're going to
go places we're going to see things
we're going to meet people we're going
to see the world we're going to you know
we're gonna we're gonna travel yeah yeah
yeah right i'm up there popping it
there's a whole
task that's a whole [ __ ] wwe royal
rumble
literally i'm like damn wow helicopter
came she ran out but naked like in the
forest
so you kind of felt bad so you're like
you know what keep you around you you
lost the tooth yeah like this and then
obviously i heard a song or two that i
liked yeah so she was like your artist
it's so random because the last time you
guys had drama a few months ago i had
somebody hit me up like hey you got a
plug on that girl i want to get a
feature from her i'm like what yeah yeah
no so
me me turning a negative to a positive
was
signing her and trying to you know make
her an artist right you know because she
had a song or two that i liked
like her music wasn't terrible yeah it
wasn't terrible and she played it for me
like you know like i said i take the
girls to the studio like we do
activities you know it's not like we're
just in the house
fighting all day right so let's get that
back so yeah i took her to the studio
heard the music i'm like okay
[ __ ] there's all right let's let's let's
try it
get on a song remix one of her songs get
on the song
um shoot videos i got her videos with
real goats
i'm plugging her in she's what right
she's going out in ross live stream
millions of views off the first day that
she decided she wants to be an artist
all this is happening
so in a way it kind of
affected her hustle
hmm
kind of she kind of got a little lazy
yeah yeah like it affected her hustle
because it was just happening like you
know you know usually when you okay
today i'm gonna be a rapper
you start off with like a thousand views
maybe your first video of course you
just kind of put her straight into the
game she went straight into the millions
i'm like so it kind of like
kind of like you know put a little
poison in her in a way
to where she yeah she got real
comfortable real just
just lazy like so are y'all expecting a
child
no bro no you look at the test
i just saw i just saw that you told her
submit and she said summit and i think
she thought she was using the word the
right way
and i was like like
she said yeah i'll sum it
yeah i were to submit you sent her the
definition
no literally i said to the screen
like this is what it means like she
thinks i'm trying to like tell her like
i'm manipulating her like i'm telling
her exactly what i wanted to do like i
want you i got to be like you know walk
a certain way talk a certain way you
just can't be raunchy like right
you know you're going to scare people
you're going to scare the business all
right right right
so i was trying to kind of groom her
but it just
she's
ungroomable she's uncle sorry is that um
relationship professionally personally
severed or is it something that still
could potentially be patched up
because like you said you might you know
she might have some talent on the music
side like
or is it just too much yeah it's just
too much
it's not a
i don't think she really desires to be
an artist you know